elles ont pris la direction de lviv une
ville à l'ouest de l'ukraine les deux
tourangelle que l'on suit depuis le
début de la semaine continue de venir en
aide à ceux qui veulent fuir leur pays
la ville de lviv est un point de passage
obligé pour se rendre en pologne là bas
ils avaient les élus ont déposé leurs
derniers dons récoltés en france résumé
de leur troisième jours de périple avec
michael texier
après plusieurs heures de route dans la
montagne isabelle et zélie sont arrivés
à lviv lieu de rassemblement de milliers
d'ukrainiens qui fuient les conflits
vers la pologne
en est à l'université où on vient de
déposer nos derniers donc qui viennent
de france et donc ce sont des étudiants
qui font partie du comité qui nous ont
aidés à les transporter
et puis direction la gare pour les deux
tours on gèle il ya déjà pas mal de
réfugiés c'est le seul endroit
beaucoup de gens tirent les puisque dans
la
c'est fluide mais là j'ai quasiment il
ya des groupes partout on voit des bus
qui par delà les frontières qui sont
plus que bons des go
dont la rue des bénévoles prennent en
charge les réfugiés qui arrivent par
vagues
parmi la foule des soldats ukrainien
zélie isabelle participent tous les
chargements de dons
partir
dans un train qui va arriver sous peu
mais en fait personne à l'information
soit il arrive maintenant ou soit yaris
casar et de la même façon les trains qui
arrivent de l'est humanitaire devait
déjà être là khelil son âge
la circulation des trains est perturbée
par un cessez-le-feu très précaire
isabelle et zélie restent sur place dans
cette ville qui vit au rythme du
couvre-feu et de l'arrivée des réfugiés